I would,
Lauren asks,
I would love to hear you do a lecture series on raising children properly.
Is that something you would consider?
Well,
in my new book,
I've written a chapter on that called don't let your children do anything that
makes you dislike them.
And I've laid out a bunch of,
uh,
I've laid out a philosophy of care and discipline that's predicated partly on a
French philosophical legal notion,
which is do not multiply rules beyond necessity.
It's sort of like illegal equivalent to all comes razor and an English common
law principle is which is used minimal necessary force.
And I think the Union of those two,
which is don't have too many rules,
but make sure that you properly enforced the ones that you do have is a good
start for how you might consider your attitude with regards to raising children.
The other thing you have to figure out is exactly what's your aim.
And you know,
one of the aims that people have had most recently pushed by clueless
psychologists,
I would say,
is that you want children to have high self esteem.
And uh,
that's actually a large part trait.
Neuroticism anyways,
but by,
and it can be modified to some degree.
Jerome Kagan has done some very interesting work on that.
But,
um,
the best thing to do,
I think the best thing to orient yourself towards with regards to children is
that you're trying to make your child,
your children or help your children to be delightful in the eyes of others.
And so that means they have to be reasonably well socialized.
And that really takes place between the ages of two and four.
Because what you want for your children is that when they go out into public,
when they're away from you or even with you for that matter,
what you want for your children is for other people to genuinely like them.
Because if they behave reasonably and they attend properly to adults and they
know how to play with other children,
then wherever they go,
they're going to be,
um,
unless they encountered someone truly malevolent,
they're going to be welcomed with smiles and open arms.
And that's not going to be fake because almost every human being actually likes
children if they're reasonably behaved.
And so your job is to make your children highly socially desirable because that
opens up the world to them.
So they're,
that's not a lecture series,
but it's a little lecture.